each year Microsoft research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely
available so I will start with um the
speakers giving us 10minute talks of
what their work is about and uh during
the transition period you you will take
a question or two but towards after
they're done with the slides that's
where we get to ask them a lot of
questions so um you can save your bigger
questions for the end as well because we
will have time so let me start with the
first Speaker our first speaker will be
Miss Sharon kellet who is the director
of Technology policy in our group and
she is managing policy uh aspects
related to 5G and net neutrality uh in
the mobility networking group at
Microsoft so let me welcome Sharon
here
everybody hi everybody and welcome to
the afternoon
session I so last night at dinner
somebody asked me what does the G stand
for is it gravity is it gigabits and I
said well no actually it's generation so
5G is about the fifth generation or the
Next Generation if you will of mobile
networks and um you most of us in this
room would think of 5G as being what's
the technology going to be you know
what's cool about the next uh technology
that's coming and the people who are
talking after me will address that
wonderfully interesting issue uh however
uh I just want to point out that what
technology gets actually built and
deployed in the field is actually shaped
by a lot more than just what's
technically possible it also uh the
reason that companies the mobile
operators will move to another
generation of networks is uh because
they want to grow their business
and in order to grow their businesses
they're looking for new markets and new
business models and New Opportunities
and what they're allowed to do in that
space and what spectrum what Wireless
Spectrum or frequency bands are going to
be available to them to do that is
heavily dependent on decisions that the
government's going to make so the first
and and when we say the government is
not a one government it's governments
all over the world and sometimes it's
not even governments acting alone but in
concert and so we'll talk about that uh
the first question is uh will new
Spectrum be available for 5G and if so
when and the answer to the first
question is maybe maybe new Spectrum
will be available and the second
question is when to when is in a long
time not anytime super soon okay and to
understand why that's true I've given
you just a really quick primer on what
the process looks like for spectrum to
become available there are two steps to
getting Spectrum into somebody's hands
uh the first step is called allocation
and that's about uh a a global
harmonization of what particular
Spectrum bands can be used for so does
this particular banded this particular
frequencies get used for satellites does
it get used for mobile phones does it
get used for the Navy that's allocation
and um the itu which is the in an
international organization
intergovernmental organization uh is the
agency there or U I guess it's part of
the United Nations uh they are the
agency that harmonizes frequency
allocations worldwide
and everybody would like 5G Spectrum to
be harmonized worldwide if they could
get that because it would be much easier
to manufacture equipment to one set of
bands rather than 40 sets of bands which
is how it was done in 4G um so uh it
would be great if they were harmonized
we'll see how close they can get um
Beyond Al and and by the way in the itu
speak their word for 5G is IMT 2020 uh
5G is a little easier to say I think um
the uh when when the itu gets done with
their work then the national governments
say okay well you want to use that ban
for
cellular all right now let's decide who
actually gets use of that band in our
country and by what process do we
auction the Spectrum do we give it away
uh those kinds of decisions that process
is called assignment and uh and um each
national government can do it
differently for the same set of
bands and that process takes a very long
time it's typically about 5 to 10 year
process to get any new Spectrum into the
market uh part of why it all takes so
long is that um the uh itus processes
were developed in an era that where time
moved a little more slowly I think than
it does today I think the T Paul would
know for sure the original t would have
been telegraphed in 1865 is that right
yes right so give you an idea this the
time frame that the world was moving at
was a little slower back then
uh in any case they in their current
world they run uh something called A
World radio Congress uh people in the
know refer to it as a work to me that
sounds like something out of a tolken
novel but I'm leaving that aside uh the
work is held every three to four years
and the works are where Spectrum uh
allocation decisions are are made uh
there's one coming up this November we
actually have uh at least one person
going to it uh in in November probably
more uh and in fact he's not here today
because he's in Bucharest Romania
getting ready for it um but what the war
15 will be doing is looking for
frequency bands that could be used for
IMT 2020 otherwise known as 5G uh it's
viewed as highly unlikely that any bands
below 6 gigahertz will actually be
identified in November but more likely
that uh bands higher than 6 gigahertz um
will be put on an agenda for study and
um what that means is that some sometime
by uh work 19 which is the next one in
2019 will um will uh will uh could could
possibly become devoted to 5G at that
time a different aspect of policy that
affects what uh what providers can do is
how how incentivized they are to uh to
deploy new technology do they have a
strong incentive to beat their
competitors or do they not have any
competitors so uh that will be
determined by Regulators who determine
who's allowed to merge with whom uh and
um and whether uh a third party can come
along and use the network to build some
kind of innovative model on top of
somebody else's facilities so an example
the first case of a what we call a
horizontal merger two networks merging
with each other uh in the US a few years
ago AT&T wanted to acquire T-Mobile
T-Mobile is known as the Innovative or
disruptive Network operator um both the
justice department and the FCC at the
time time said no you can't do that uh
it's bad competition policy we're going
to leave T-Mobile out there to to keep
being a thorn in your side um and you
know innovating and being an uncarrier
and all that jazz uh so that's an
example we're uh you know depending on
exactly what kind of mergers are or are
not allowed uh there will be different
levels of pressure on incumbents to try
to differentiate their networks with new
technology uh how many of you are
familiar with the word
mvno most of you know the term okay good
um so uh essentially an mvno is a
reseller right they're buying the
capacity on a facilities based carriers
Network and offering it in a different
package to customers and uh one of those
models that's out there today is one
called Wi-Fi first the idea being that
uh instead of you buy a package from the
cellular company and then you add Wi-Fi
to it for your high bandwidth needs
rather you buy a package from a company
like Republic Wireless
or uh you know uh Google fi is as an
example of this you use Wi-Fi for most
of your needs and when you get out of
Wi-Fi coverage um the MV agreement kicks
in and you end up using the uh capacity
from a traditional cellular carrier and
so uh one of the questions that
competition policy deals with is okay so
are those arrangements regulated or are
those arrangements privately negotiated
and if they're privately negotiated as
they are in the US where are the limits
of those uh an unassociated
issue uh one of the things that's
cropped up and this is not so much about
5G but more about you know ways in which
technology is actually changing that
might shape 5G um a new a new technology
has emerged which is to aggregate
licensed and unlicensed Spectrum into a
single use uh and the generic name for
this is LTE over unlicensed bands um and
the basic ideas Illustrated in the
picture a licensed carrier takes their
uh licensed Channel uses it as a control
Channel bonds it with the unlicensed the
5 gahz in particular Wi-Fi spectrum and
uh and Aggregates it into something that
the carrier can use and there's big big
big questions about what that's going to
do to Wi-Fi performance and there isn't
one answer to that question because
there's at least four different variants
that I've counted so far of of ways to
do LTE over unlicensed and they have
widely different competitive profiles so
some of them might coexist fairly with
the Wi-Fi some of them might not uh and
so this is a area where Spectrum policy
and competition policy are kind of
merged into one big question and uh
regulat this is one where up to this
point I've talked about ways policy is
going to shape the technology I think
this is one where technolog is going to
push the policy makers to have to make
some decisions about what it really
means to have rules about unlicensed
Spectrum I'll conclude with some
thoughts about Network neutrality is
there anyone in this room who has not
heard of net
neutrality okay I figure you've heard of
it um the question is what effect does
it have on 5G and um the gist of the of
net neutrality is that um that the
internet is you know a bunch of
applications Services content and so on
that's available through a network and
how much control does the network
operator allowed to have over uh what
the user experiences in terms of the
applications and uh services and content
and um what um what uh the the US
adopted a new set of rules in the end of
February in the EU literally this
morning the text came out of what it is
they about to formalize in the EU uh and
the gist of what they have done is as
follows uh they've defined two different
things one is an open internet and the
other is something else which they go by
the name of specialized services so
inter internet access is a service where
the ISP is very limited in terms of what
they are allowed to uh to do um they're
not allowed to block or throttle and
generally it's an economic there there
there's both political and economic
reasons why they might do that uh they
might do it politically because they
don't like what a speaker has to say so
they would block that content they might
do it economically because they would
like the speaker to have to pay them in
order to transmit that content and that
is what uh that's called blocking
throttle or requiring pay for priority
and that's what net neutrality says
can't happen on your internet access
pipe but what about the other pieces of
your pipe you have a network it goes to
your house or to your office and uh what
else can you do with it besides access
the internet so uh do any of you get
voice from your cable company for
example you get telephone service from
your cable company no one in the room
does wow okay um okay well if you did
the FCC would consider that a uh what
they call Specialized Service in other
words it's not something you're using to
reach the entire internet um and so they
have carved that out and said okay those
are different that's not the same as
internet access and net neutrality rules
don't apply um in the interest of time
I'll set aside zero rate and come back
to it if you have questions um the
reason this relates to 5G is that the
business models for 5G are very much all
about finding new Revenue opportunities
for mobile operators and in order to do
that there's two ways you can do that
you can offer the services yourself and
not allow third parties to offer them or
you can say to the third party you know
what I want you to be able to offer that
service but I also want you to have to
pay me to get better quality out of my
network for it and uh and so there's an
open question as to whether those models
will be considered specialized services
or whether those models will be
considered open internet access and I
think that's going to be a tussle that
we're going to be watching playing out
over over the next uh few years as 5G
develops and often there are numerous
scenarios that that are tossed out like
connected cars for example that you know
it must be offered by the operator and
you know we'll see uh to to be
determined um how much time do I have
left zero okay then I won't tell you
about zero rating I'll leave it for the
questions and if you have questions
about it I'm happy to explain what that
issue is all about
thanks
thanks Sharon hopefully you now know
that 5G will not only be about what
technolog is feasible but also about how
the network operators can maximize
revenue and how what applications can
you make possible so to hear about what
applications can you make feasible with
uh 5G we will have here sandep rangan
he's from NYU and he has a lot of
Industry experience as well he
co-founded flan Technologies which was a
spin-off of B labs and he has also
worked at Qualcomm where he was the
director of engineering for the ofdm uh
infrastructure products so I will give
it to
sandep all right thanks sir
kka yeah um one thing I'm actually not
going to talk about is what you can do
with 5G that's that's one of my
questions at the end but um maybe I'll
try to say what what maybe one way you
can create uh 5G to work
so
oh it comes out in
blue okay um well okay I'd like to thank
everyone for giving me a chance to uh
speak at this uh panel there are
actually going to be a couple of other
speakers talking about millimeter wave
what I wanted to do uh in this talk is
really talk about it specifically in the
context of cellular which is a
relatively new concept and I'll show you
why that is new but also relatively
exciting so how do I get this to move
does this go ahead it doesn't seem
to technology
yeah yeah maybe you should just do it
manually
oh you want to do okay yeah um just that
I'm going to talk about some of the um
work with uh that done but also just
work generally done at the NYU Wireless
Center one person I want to point out in
particular is Ted rapor who's sometimes
called the father the Messiah of
millimeter wave um he's as maybe some
people know he's rather sick right now
and we hoping he can get better and else
Eric who's also a faculty
member all right um just to put before I
talk about millimeter wave let me just
talk about 5G in general or basically 5G
cellular and what people are trying to
achieve by this this comes from Nokia
but you'll see kind of a similar set of
requirements for most of the uh vendors
and if you look at that set of list it's
really daunting the kind of things that
people are looking at orders of
magnitude increases in data rate and
reductions in latency what's important
to understand is that when you're
looking at 5G it has many requirements
but not all of these requirements have
to be met at the same time or delivered
by the same technology and millimeter
wave is really trying to emphasize just
a couple of these things that those are
those orders of magnitude increases
um data rate as well as these reduction
in latency down to about say about 1
milliseconds which about an order of
magnitude less than it is on the other
hand there are other things like much
lower batter much greater battery life
and those would obviously have to be
addressed by other types of Technologies
all right so what is millimeter wave so
millimeter wave millimeter refers to the
wavelength and if you look at what one
um millimeter to 10 millimet that
corresponds to about frequencies in the
neighborhood of 30 to 300 GHz and why
are they interested in this well this
the best way to look at is through this
figure which really comes out from the
seminal paper if you really want to
learn more about this i' start with this
paper from Samsung and if you look at
here on the uh left all Cellular
Communications right now commercial
occurs in that tiny band in that black
below 3 gigahertz now this is become
extremely congested as networks try to
expand capacity how congested is right
now just to give you an example the last
speaker was talking about uh Spectrum
auctions they recently tried to auction
off the What's called the aw us uh
spectrum and just 60 mahz in that
bandwidth went for a record-breaking I
think like $46 billion so you can see
how just prohibitively expensive it is
to try to increase capacity in this band
millimeter wave just is to scale is all
that space there like maybe and that's
how much more space is that if uh well
immediately in the short term they're
probably bands in about the 28 GHz range
the 70 GHz range and if you look that
maybe about if you look going forward
maybe up to 100 maybe even 200 times
more spectrum is available on top of
that spectrum is that you can make uh
arrays with many many antenna elements
in the same in for in a very small space
and that what that means is that you can
get what call very high numbers of
spatial degrees of freedom you can
transmit in many directions at a time so
when you put these two together you're
talking about networks within capacities
maybe 100 maybe even a thousand times
more capacity than what you have today
now how big is that well if you look at
in comparison in the cellular world
where I've worked in some if you look at
a compara to technology say like myo
which was one of the biggest inventions
that came out in the mid beginning of
the mid 90s took about 10 years really
to get fully through the system the kind
of ingrain you got was about maybe 60%
60% greater capacity per base station
when you actually look at the realistic
implementations here you have a
technology that's possibly orders of
magnitude this this kind of change is
really revolutionary it just does not
occur that often another way to look at
it is the following um almost every
aspect just go back sorry um uh almost
every aspect of technology has uh of
mobile technology is increased in order
to mag what are you looking at the
processor speed the memory the storage
on the other hand the spectrum that
we've been looking at is really same as
what were networks were back in the GSM
era 203 years ago and so it's really
right right now to try to look
technology that can push out into these
higher bands okay let's go that being
said the there's enormous potential but
there is very serious challenges if you
look back at papers even just five years
ago they will say millimeter wave is
great for a and C but it can never of
course be used for Mobile Cellular why
not well there's two main reasons the
first is um that the Transmissions that
are fundamentally Limited in terms of um
of propagation for technical I don't
want to go over here because I only have
10 minutes but there you can kind of you
can overcome that but what you have to
do is transmit in highly directional uh
beams now that makes it very difficult
potentially in a cellular environment
where objects are moving that means
you'll need to track them and also
search and also for control and other
things but the bigger problem with it is
what's called shadowing one of the great
things about cellular frequencies today
is that they can propagate you can most
of you if you have your cell phone on
you you can see that you can get a
signal inside a building like this in
millimeter wave that becomes very
difficult a lot of um basic materials
particular materials where they have a
lot of water can absorb the uh signals
and even something like the human body
can absorb the signal can block the
signal that means that if you turn your
uh uh turn your body that signal can get
blocked from the base station so these
are fundamental problems on the other
hand these materials also provide lots
of reflecting paths and we'll see that
it might be possible to get a signal all
right next one next
slide let's see have drop both so when
we're thinking about millimeter wave
cell
what we're thinking about are a few
things first of all smalls that are
small maybe in the order of about 100
200 met that's actually about the same
size though as current Urban
microcellular deployments so it's still
not necessarily a greater increase in
density on the other hand we're looking
at very narrow beams that are constantly
searching around to the users and you
may also try to do some kind of range
extension by doing some kind of relaying
or multihop um so all those those are
sort of three elements that you should
think of when you think of what way
people are think about fam cellular all
right so can these work well like I said
a few years ago before if you asked for
someone in the business they would have
said it would never been possible so Ted
rapor who was been working in this area
for you know 20 years he had joined NYU
our school and one of the things he did
was the uh following just to test it out
if you might recognize that's uh the
Washington Square campus in the village
in New York City and so this is an
extremely dense uh uh area of buildings
if it could work work in New York it
could work anywhere because this is um
one of the most difficult environments
to get a line of sight connection so he
placed um cells on tops of buildings on
those yellow stars and then he went
around or his students went around in
the hot sun and tried to see where they
could get a signal and look at where he
could get a signal this we get the
signal all the way to the green dots so
look at that signal way up for example
on that top dot there is no line of
sight connection what's a line of sight
connection it means that you can see the
transmitter well you definitely cannot
treat that's two blocks in New York City
with many many buildings in between it
and yet you could see that now you're
thinking how is that on Earth possible I
told you it can never go through
buildings well it finds reflecting paths
and this was a remarkable finding and it
meant that this could even though
millimeter signals get blocked a lot of
these building materials are highly
reflective and that eventually you could
find a path and in fact you could make
some spatial measurements not only find
one but maybe up to on average about two
or three paths on to most receiver
locations and this suggested that
millimeter wave signals would actually
be possible millimet transmit be
actually be possible in these uh
networks all right uh this is too
technical let's skip it I don't want to
get all right so we took these um
measurements that from Ted rorts and
said well okay that maybe that you could
say well you saw a signal that doesn't
necessarily mean much how much more
capacity Could you actually get well
there's a standard methodology for
anyone who worked in the cellular
business once you have some sort of
statistical Channel model based on these
measurements you can try to predict how
well the capacity is so we did the
following we just turned that crank
looking at these Channel models and made
a simple comparison let's look at a
comparison of a one potential 1 GHz
system in the lmds band that's 28 GHz
and uh so 1 GHz is very easy to get in
this band because this is actually uh
that's that's not a large bandwidth in
that and compared it to the widest band
width single carrier um LTE system which
is a 20 MHz Uplink and 20 MHz down link
so about 25 times more bandwidth and
then you look at the total gain you uh
run this number and according to that
simulation if this if these Channel
models are correct then you could get
about a 25 times gain of that that is
just enormous now and on top of that
even the edge of cell users those are
kind of the worst users would you think
would really suffer in a millimeter wave
system get about a 10 times gain now on
top of the this is is looking at a very
Bare Bones um millimeter wave system
without any bells and whistles on the
other hand the LTE numbers for those who
have know the standards where you get
that from is that the vendors when they
try to introduce Technologies they put
in their best most sophisticated system
with all the best bells and W Stones
like sdma and uh you know very
sophisticated inter cell interference
coordination and they put their those in
and even then we're beating it by this
25x number clearly we could even do
large ler so this is some validation
that it's may be possible to get an
extremely high bandwidth um wide area
network right all right um we can talk
much more about the details of this but
I was want to leave in for this audience
because I know this audience is more I'm
more of a physical layer person but up
to a higher layer to try to just put out
a couple of questions that maybe we can
uh get to in the panel discussion the
first is even if this technology is
possible what kind of apps will actually
drive that and I I that's not I don't
believe disbelieve that these kind of
higher data rates or much lower
latencies can get used but I think if we
get some understanding of that um that
might be able to help better understand
how these networks will be used and how
we need to design them the um the other
uh part is what will really Drive in
particular the very low latency and also
um which is one of the dominant
requirements and we saw that from the
previous talk and that will also require
sort of fundamental changes in the the
network infrastructure as well and that
for example that will require you know
even if we got the network latency the
airlink latency down to 1 MC to take
advantage of that we'll need to start
pushing content much closer to the edge
of the network and that will also
require change fundamental changes the
way that the uh Network infrastructure
is um worked out and I want to maybe
speculate on uh maybe we can come to
that in the panel discussion as well
about uh um how that implications that
all right thanks
thank you sandep that was a great uh
starting point of what capacities are
possible with uh we can take a question
here while I switch the slides Victor go
ahead hi I'm sort of curious about
couple things first why did you call the
2011 as a seminal paper and the of the
Samsung especially because the notion of
Reflections is known for a long time in
fact it was a Samsung CEO in 2010 CES
who demonstrated that you could using
sbeam sa beam's uh equipment you could
actually send a beam and have a human
beams walk around and they would reflect
off of the different services and still
get it so this has been known for for
ages and the second thing is I think the
issue is the last uh particular uh slide
that he put which is that it's not that
people don't understand the technology
and they don't understand what the
coverage patterns is is really uh
economics who's what's going to drive
the cost to create the C
so um I sort of want to know why I mean
you know what are your thoughts on the
fact that people have sort of kind of I
think known about a lot of these issues
for oh yeah yeah okay so first of all
yeah it's a good point so first of all
the um millimeter we propagation has
been well known and of course the
reflective properties of millimeter wave
systems on particular on indoors have
been measured since the me measured
since the since the 70s what I think
that paper was and maybe there was maybe
it was I in my view the first that
really looked at it comprehensively for
an out wide area cellular network and
that was what uh that was why it was so
U interesting people were of course
already by that time were you know well
into looking at w Wireless lenss and
other sort of more short-range
Technologies on the question of the
economics I think that's the you know
that's the million-- dooll question and
that isn't specific to millimeter W but
to a lot of 5G Technologies of what's
going to be the driving need for
operators to whove invested you know
billions of dollars on 4G to try to
upgrade that now they already think 4G
itself can expand you know just by
regular Evolution and so it will have to
be something that's going to you know
looking maybe in the 21 2021 time frame
of something that will really motivate
these kind of data rates so I think
that's a excellent question I don't
think that's
known thanks and leave and thanks Victor
for the question next up we have Shinu
Zang uh he's a professor at University
of Wisconsin Madison and uh he has a
great set of achievements behind him
already uh he has an ACM uh mobicom best
paper award NSF career award and uh I'm
sure he'll win many more but today he
will talk to us about um indoor
Communications with millimeter wave and
what's possible and what he has seen in
these um regime thank you um there are
many definitions of 5G at this time
people don't really know what exactly is
5G I think so it's a good time to talk
something random about 5G I think um so
what I'm going to talk about is the
concept of unifying 5G millimeter wave
communication and
sensing um first uh some first of all
some background about millimeter wave
networking uh this millimeter wave
networks uh they have a great potential
and have some unique features compared
with what we are using on the cellular
band currently the spect on the cular
band is only 1.3 GHz in total among 2G
3G and 4G but for mimer wave we have
sufficient Spectrum even for un licensed
we have 7 GHz and there are some light
licensed 13 gahz and some licensed but
potentially can be unlicensed uh a lot
of spectrums uh there available for us
to use and with such Spectrum we can
achieve very high bit trate
Communications up to m po Giga BPS
because of this many new applications
can be enabled for example uh Indo in
home in store or in Flight media
distribution high stream uncompressed
video distribution to support uh Mirror
card uh where is virtual reality and the
mobile to kiosk uh file
sync on the other hand we can also
realize short range highspeed
Communications for for example in
between base stations in a 5G uh
cellular band um and also in between the
base stations and mobile handset for
very short range small Cale or Pico cell
networks these are just some
communication applications but we can
also have some mobile sensing
applications based on MIM wave for
example recently Google released this
project solely which is a 60 gz mm wave
chipset that can recognize a setle
gestures
and our group had a more ambitious
project which can recognize which can
check pen movement to realize Wireless
transcription using 6 gz radios this
paper will be published uh in ASM mobile
com this
year so because of these two lines of
applications communication and sensing
what I was thinking about is we can
actually unify this uh communication
sensing in the 5G mill millimeter wave
Networks by unification uh I mean two
aspects first of all we can directly use
the communication interface on the 5G M
wave radios to realize some interesting
mobile sensing applications like the
project Sol that I mentioned and also we
can use the stening function to help
communication or networking uh the first
aspect actually many people are doing it
uh on the Wi-Fi domain so today I will
mainly talk about the second aspect that
is using the s in function to facilitate
5G millim wave
networking so uh one of the major
concern about M wave networking is the
propagation loss all all things equal
the propagation loss at 60 Herz is about
30 DB higher compared with Wi-Fi so many
people are thinking about using highly
directional radios to concentrate the
signals to overcome the propagation loss
however this will introduce more
challenges for example the radius become
highly vulnerable to uh blockage and
device
motion uh on the other hand people are
thinking about using a unique device
feature to overcome such challenges that
is we can use very small form factor
phase array to generate highly
directional beams and steer the beams to
overcome the uh device motion or human
blockage uh recently we did some
experiment to test this kind of flexible
beam Communications for 60 Herz MIM Wave
Communications but what we found is that
this is not necessar working well and
whether it works or not is highly
dependent on environmental context in
some kind of situations um the the uh
beam steering may work in some kind of
some other kind of uh situations it
simply adapting the bean withd will work
and whether it will work will also
depend on whether there's uh reflectors
and reflector positions and uh where the
human blockage is happening all such
environmental and context
factors so we were thinking about
whether we can learn such environmental
environmental context in order to help
network level management and protal
level
adaptation so uh this the answer is
actually a easy yes because minim wave
radius is Bor to be a highly sensitive
sensor to sense the context in the minim
w radar domain people have some
fundamental laws they are saying that
the sensitivity of a radio is
proportional to the wavelength so at
millimeter wave the wav length is only a
few millimeters much much shorter
compared with the microwave band so
millimet wave radius can naturally
become highly sensitive sensors for
environmental
context some examples of how we can take
advantage of the sensing functionality
to help network and protal Design This
example shows how we can learn
environment in a way similar to a room
Acoustics in order to understand how to
place the 60 HZ MIM V radius to improve
its coverage in room Acoustics people
have learned how to reshape the room in
order to make the sounding effect better
similarly in a MIM Wave radio
environment we can also learn how the
environment looks like and which uh kind
of placement of access point can help us
improve the radio coverage this of
course requires the radio themselves to
be cognitive and to sense the
environment in a way similar to rad in
order to understand the environment and
help the network
adaptation another example we usually
have a lot of beam directions when we
use the phase array antenna to realize
the flexible beam communication
adapting to different directions
involves a lot of overhead but there's
some correlation between all those
directions and we can learn correlation
as long as we know the environment very
well so we can again take advantage of
the sensing function in 6 Dez radius to
learn the environment and to learn the
correlation between beams and adapt in a
more intelligent way to reduce the
network level
overhead in order to realize all these
ideas an unification of communication
and sensing ideas we need to do a a lot
of experimental verification we can no
longer do simulation because all these
things this sensing this environment and
human activities they are non stationary
we cannot profile them using models or
using statistics so we need to have a
real test
bed and many people are concerned about
the lack of test bed in 60 Herz and
actually this has been a bar for the
millimet wave research so recently our
group built this uh Wii Wisconsin MIM
wave software radio which is a
programmable transmitter and receiver
and also a programable m 60 radar that
can be used to realize sensing and
imaging
functions this uh this programmable
system contains UH 60 HZ antenna set
that can be changed and steered
mechanically and it has a bband
processor Ser is about 245 MHz of
sampling rate and its RF front end is
also programmable in terms of the output
power level and also the um band WDS
analog band
WDS this is the um software radio
platform supported by NSF C program and
will be released as open source firmware
and Hardware together uh it's a bit
expensive and it although it's it's
opens Source we just have to make sure
we have sufficient money to to use it
and we are also going to build a second
version with much more powerful
capabilities like uh Ultra whiteband and
the programable pH array antenna as well
as myo
functionalities so in summary I have
talked about the uh some um potential of
MIM Wave Communications for the 60 hertz
uh especially the 60 Herz MIM Wave
Communications and I talked about why we
need to unify this um communication and
sensing at millim wave domain and why we
can do it um so that's it thank
you do we have a question for Shinu
right
now I have a quick question he talked
about spatial correlation if I want to
place multiples such devices indoors uh
what what do we learn based on your work
how do we handle myu
indoors so there's spatial correlation
spatial correlation will definitely
affect the mimo performance uh because
we know that myo gain is dependent on
The Matrix Channel Matrix rank uh so we
can easily learn about spatial
correlation as long as we can probe the
channel and spal correlation again is
dependent on environment for example if
the uh other radius are in live s side
of course the correlation is high and
even in non-li site we can learn about
that uh the spatial coration by scanning
the channel so that's a very easy thing
actually based on if we can sense the if
we can sense the channel
Matrix okay thank you uh go ahead
Victor very quick question with your
test bed what is the range that you have
seen in your test
bed right now we have we have haven't
done a extreme test yet right now what
and the maximum range we tested is 7 m
of course it depends on the modulation
we used and also the uh what what do you
think is happening with the
NYU um test bed uh NYU test bed is using
a different RF front end and also
different baseband processor and
different antennas I think uh with that
test bed set up it's very easy to
achieve 100 meter range because uh they
are using the slide uh correlator it's
essentially a high performance Channel
Sounder it will definitely have better
range than ours but our objective is not
coverage our objective is the
programmability
flexibility we have one more
question I was wondering about your
antenna and RF front end did you build
that yourself
or no we are just engineers assembling
other people's thing together uh the
other front end was uh purchased from
startup company and Bas band is
essentially just an fpga and there's
highspeed ad da we are just putting all
of them together and build the brid and
hardware and also the firmware driver
firmware drivers the
anten right uh no not antenna the RF
front end means the frequency up
converter and down
converters the antennas uh can be
purchased from many companies
actually thanks J um next up we'll have
Heather um and she will she is currently
an associate professor at UC Santa
Barbara uh where she leads the link lab
as part of the Next Generation
networking group she has a lot of
Industry research experience including
uh at Microsoft research Asia and she
has gotten many awards uh I have a long
list here but the one I will mention is
that her work has been featured in MIT
technology review and she's gotten
Bella's president's Gold Award and so on
so without further Ado I'll let her talk
about her work and she has actually
tried deploying outdoor Pico cells with
um 60 GHz
work
okay great um
so by now you actually learned a lot
about millimeter wave so what I'm going
to do is trying to focus more on 6 gahz
because I think that's a particular
swiet spot um for economics like
answering trying to answering vector's
earlier question so 6 gigahertz it's um
has a very large chunk of unlicensed
Spectrum so we kind of get rid of the LI
the licensing and the policy issues it's
a very high frequency millimeter wave
frequency so you can have very large
compressed array base and that create
highly directional beams you can
concentrate TR I mean significant amount
of energy and also reduce a lot of
interference and this will be very
useful for our five or future networking
design and the last one is that oops
this one is too sensitive it's
leveraging existing standards there are
already 8 in 11 ad so you already have
the standard issue I mean solved and
today we seeing these products I mean on
the market right so and Dell used to
have a laptop with a docking station
which the chipset cost 37 I mean dollar
IBM um um actually HP just released
another one with Intel chipset with
similar cost I've seen startups saying
that their chip actually cost $5 each so
this will be integrated like into all
future smartphones as part of the Wi-Fi
which means that we solve the standard
the protocol some kind of
standardization and the uh license
issues okay so 62 GHz today being widely
used for indoor y gig all these
different um uh Technologies and some of
the outdoor in terms of stationer
Network so we're thinking a slightly
different manner what if we take 6 gahz
outdoor as a cellular part of cellular
networks think about the following
scenario I have LTE which provide me the
availability mean availability just
connectivity for your connection and
then I also have some kind of 60 GHz
base stations overlay small picle cells
which provide high capacity when you
need it so considering the following
where you have a base station and each
base station will have multiple attenna
arrays each array will Target one
particular user so this way each Bas
station can cover multiple many users
user
simultaneously and because of the
interference issue is kind of solved by
the directionality of the transmission
these base station or the Pico cell can
overlap significantly and that provide
you high density coverage and high
capacity and also availability for some
of the
users so think about the following real
life examples consider this is a New
York City street um you have lamp poost
we can potentially put those space
station on top of the lamp poost over
here so you have power or you can use
you know uh solar and you can basically
use these to serve the users underneath
the street incentive says the street and
all these building provide perfect
reflectors and allow you to connect
users even when their position is not
correctly facing the base station so
these give you significant amount of the
advantage so why 60 GHz okay if you look
at from the capacity
point of
view the spectrum is significant you
have high
bandwidths the um array give you
significant amount of spatial diversity
so you can basically special
multiplexing a lot of user using arrays
of subarrays like I just mentioned and
finally these very narrow beams allow
you to significantly minimize
interference allow the dense cell to be
deployed so we've actually looked at
some calculations and we' find out that
if can overlay all these cells every 20
M they should not interfere
significantly with each other so this
means that you can really significant
increase your capacity in all three
important Dimension so if you say oh
this seems pretty good but a lot of
people are very concerned about this why
would I want to use a 60 gigahertz there
are papers or there are articles talk
about we don't want to use 60 gahz
because the oxygen absor ition as I mean
Peak at this kind of frequency so the
first thing people are thinking is maybe
the range is too small that's why you
using the indoor right so what we did is
we actually set up a um test bed 60 GHz
test bed using the offshelf uh velocity
chipsets and we kind of measured you
know all these um ranges and other
different question what we found of I
mean interesting things the first thing
is that the range can actually be more
than 100 meter depending on your
Hardware device right so today velocity
chipset the $37 chipset is designed for
indoor can also already give you 27 me
23 MERS at 300 megabits per second and
if you can actually improve your end
array by a little bit you can
potentially achieve more than 100 meter
in
range and second thing is you know if
you work at a high frequency you must be
very sensitive to blockage yes but 60
GHz also have very nice reflection
properties it pretty much can be reflect
different kind of materials see on the
street and outdoor environment and even
indoor environment so your reflection
through all these different material
provide you ample alternative passes
give you enough connectivity
opportunities and also as user move you
could just realign the t with each other
and we found that if you just realign
every 2 second for pedestrian that's
more than enough and in fact if you look
at today's velocity which is designed
for indoor scenario can already support
some interest I mean moderate pedestrian
speed so this means that some simple
visibility study tells us 60 gahz can be
utilized in outdoor Pico cell scenario
give you a 100 meter coverage and yet
adapt to user Mobility as well as
blockage we actually tested when The
Pedestrian walk in front of you they did
block your transmission but the
reflection or the base station diversity
I mean coming from another base station
signal can easily recover that so if
you're moving forward the key challenge
of realiz this is how do you do Network
design I think that's interesting part
of it first of all is how do you track
each user now I can dedicate part of the
array for each particular user how do
you track this user over time so you can
keep a reach pass inventory about them
and you can certainly just periodically
scan each particular user but maybe
there are much more interesting or
efficient algorithm for example we're
developing something called compressive
array adaptation at UCSB to address this
problem and second one is called picle
Cloud architecture we found from our
experiment
that if you two base station or multiple
Bas can collaborate and serve a certain
single user you can provide ample
connectivity opportunity for the users
but how do you you know let the space
station coordinate you are essentially
forming a little Cloud around each user
but how does this Cloud work with each
other especially if you have a very high
data rate in the data plan how do you
build a control plan to basically allow
them to coordinate and finally comes to
this really basic fundamental question
is we really need some Hardware we can
test the network protol designs or
algorithm designs these days you don't
we don't have a you know programmable
attenna array a lot of research we're
using hor antennas including our
research and some of the existing
antenna arrays they do not open up their
interface to us so we believe we think
that this is an important step for the
network researcher to overcome in order
to moving forward in these 6 GHz or even
millimeter wave networking area uh we're
actually uh ongoing work at ucsp and
Stanford and with SH at Wisconsin we're
trying to develop a programmable aend
array which we can hopefully open source
to the general public that's our ongoing
work that's it okay so I I also want to
mention
that like sh mentioned as well we also
have something that interesting here is
if we use radios just not for purely for
networking we can also use it for more
interesting application for example
think about these uh these Amazon or
whatever drones you're flying you can
use a 60 gz radio when they're not
needed to for communication to sense
environment we have a paper coming up
that basically can scan the objects and
then identify the shape the material and
the location of the object so that these
drones can easily pick up the object on
the flly so you can actually utilize the
network radio not only for communication
but for sensing and other interesting
applications okay so by that let me uh
conclude the talk and these are
basically our Invision architecture for
the C gers Pico cell okay thank
you thank you heather uh was there a
question right now or we can ask
questions for all the panelists at this
point do we have a question uh go ahead
Elizabeth um hi so you mentioned that
the um even though you're using narrow
beams it's acceptable for moderate
walking with a realignment about every
two seconds but what about all the other
types of movement that you would want to
cover when you're outside bikes
skateboards and then
cars good question so the thing is for
vehicle that's it's a very different
story because you have to really follow
the user really fast by that you can
actually make a compromise if you widen
the beam then the coverage of the beam
is is larger then you can follow the
user faster but by doing that you also
reduce the strength of the signal that
means the range will be reduced but
doing but so the thing is the nice thing
for that is for um C gigahertz FCC just
increase the Erp by 30 DB so you can
actually boost significantly power from
the base station to track users and if
you also use very powerful attenna for
example like say 10 x 10 attenna at the
array at the user you can still enhance
or overcome this loss in terms of signal
strength so that's actually doable as
well we haven't really tested but
theoretically that that could be doable
as well by making some sacrifices of
course thank
you more
questions uh there there was a question
there I have the same question
okay okay uh Victor go ahead to ask us
so Heather um you uh you know that you
know a lot of this work has been done
for not your particular work but for
example the bwrc senator was doing a lot
of this stuff and uh sabe I mentioned
earlier had a company with $80 million
VC funding which actually tanked and uh
velocity is there now so what is causing
this Rejuvenation of the work I don't
see any fundamental changes from what I
saw many many years ago to now that's
causing um like three of the speakers
today four right three uh talked about
60 GHz so could you give me some sense
of what what the excitement is about now
that you've discovered that you didn't
or people didn't know uh 5 10 years
ago so the exciting thing is that first
first of all um the range I think the
range is actually interesting idea so
um originally Aller people think that c
Gard because of oxygen absorption the
peak it should not be utilized I should
say that if you don't mind you should go
back to about seven years ago Bob brison
was gave a talk right here in Microsoft
research and he talked he took that on
headon about oxygen absorption and what
sort of you know implication has so that
was ALS that also has been sort of um
you know it's not been an issue for a
long time for that so you did not invite
me for
that okay so the I I think um I think
one of the thing is to me is that it
could be the timing that not at that
time maybe the 60 gz the bandwidth we
don't really need that much of a BWI
these days with all these virtual
reality like Periscope we're streaming
video constantly you know to to the to
the network and we really are pressured
by the amount of you know traffic we
need to support so I think now we're
really looking for capacity in all
different kind of ways indoor or outdoor
right so these actually Pro I mean
pressure everybody look for
alternatives to look at you know how do
I actually boost my Spectrum boost my
capacity using you know simple
economical I mean Technologies this
might actually allow us to revisit some
of the past technology but I think
that's the beauty of you know you know
how demand drives the research right and
then the thing the other thing is if you
actually can leverage the radio to do
more things like sensing or Imaging you
know this add another reach dimension on
top of the existing communication which
is the right the the if you can reduce
one device on your smartphone why not so
I think this emple you know technology
ology Advantage here is the driver so I
think this is a panel question but I'll
just raise it and be quiet after that
the question I think is what sandip
mentioned in his last slide really I
still need well I think a lot of us
still need to be convinced that the
capacity argument is actually valid in
the sense that um with small cells and
the you know LT small cells or whatever
you you mentioned a number like 300
megabits per second or in range we can
get way more than that even now without
60 gig so uh and then if you have small
cells independent of 60 GHz you actually
have a lot of capacity that in different
areas so I don't know what the driving
scenario is in all just uh in outdoor
can you actually get I I to me I still
think the capacity thing can make sense
here so the thing is have you if you use
the I mean Twitter I use Twitter
Periscope I mean those a lot of time you
won't be able to view any video because
there's the Uplink upload speed is just
zero right so I think these these
application are emerging right so I mean
it may not be so popular right now but
there are emerging these days I think
they can actually drive the future
looking at how fast they develop they
may be in infancy right now but they
could actually take off and we should be
prepared for that
right uh let's let's uh request the
speakers to be in aan and I think we can
take this question uh in a broader way
uh I would request Shinu syip and Sharon
to join us for
uh on chairs here and and let's direct
questions to all of
them yeah we'll just pass it
around so uh taking the broader question
I think the question that Victor asked
is that uh what is the killer app for
millimeter Wave Communications that you
believe will drive the the need for
capacity that you make possible both
outdoors and indoors and and we have
some answers but do any other speakers
want to answer that question maybe I'll
I what what Victor your question is
really good and I think that I've that
receive that a lot but what a lot of The
Operators will say is they they look at
just the growth rate of mobile data and
then they extrapolate that out without
and then you know you can project that
so the first thing I think maybe I
mentioned before is that 4G itself can't
expand and also you're right
densification even when I first
presented these to Qualcomm just like
two years ago they had said we don't
need millimeter wave we can just densify
the existing cells and that's been the
well that's covered a lot of the gains
that we've had over the last 10 years
but that also starts to run into
problems because the densification
itself you need to get sight placement
and you need to get a back hul which if
you know the economics of the of outdoor
networks that becomes very expensive so
you know I think there is I think there
is a feeling that at least in certain
scenarios millimeter wave will be useful
as one component of meeting capacity but
there are many other techniques and you
know that and how what are going to be
the driving applications of what's going
to continue on that curve is probably
hard to predict but on the other hand if
you look back say 10 years ago and you
asked what would be the driving data
right now for networks you might not
have been able to see that either but uh
you know one of the thing you could
imagine something like if a lot of stuff
got moved out to the cloud and we were
talking about with Sharon earlier that
might be a driving Factor although maybe
you don't need the latency and so on so
I I have a quick comment on that aspect
so uh we talked only about capacity uh
are there comments on the latency aspect
because both indoors where you have say
virtual reality and augmented reality
with Hollow lens becoming a possibility
is latency a question and if it's a back
haul between base stations Outdoors then
latency should certainly be an issue
that can millimeter wave solve
that can you guys comment on the
latencies that you experience in these
platforms when you say go from one base
station to another or from my
perspective I think latency is mainly a
problem of netw architecture if you
reduce like the number of Gateway midle
boxes and everything that will solve the
latency problem but I think for milim
wave it's mainly solving the last Hub
capacity problem that doesn't
necessarily translate into latency
that's my
thought U my view on the latency is I
think I think it really actually it
actually need for us need to think about
given the high data rate we support like
millimeter wave what do we need to
design for Network protocol to really
utilize that that the end I think that's
a rich set of question for the network
architecture design we might have to
redesign the NW architecture for that
purpose but I think that's a that's a
very rich error to look
into maybe I'll just say on the latency
if you look at the mo the best case
scenario for LTE latency now is about 22
milliseconds and that's assuming you
don't have any heart R transmission so
in practice you're looking at about air
link lat
probably more like about at least 50
milliseconds in good good scenarios and
in that case I think actually the
airlink latency is probably dominant uh
because you can get Once once you
actually if it's a wired base station
you'll get to the Gateway even if it's
like hundreds of kilometers away you can
probably get there quite fast now if if
they if there is a compelling need to
push that say an end to-end latency down
maybe in the order of like 10 millisecs
then I think we that would be an
argument for having a new tech air link
into to face but we'll also need to make
some sort of commensurate changes in the
network with what we're saying and some
of the difficult challenges there will
be to push the content earlier and I I
mentioned that the question there is
what is an Al what's an application that
needs both super low latency and very
high bandwidth and um that's not obvious
to me unless you're doing some kind of
distributed computing across both the
mobile and the cloud and that's maybe a
question I think a lot of people here
will know a better answer to like
Microsoft whether you are trying to
partition uh sources out but I don't
think there's any application today that
necessarily needs
that I'm going to let audience ask
questions otherwise I have a list of
questions but let's start with the
audience go
ahead yeah this is a question for Sharon
uh you were mentioning before uh you
didn't have time to talk about Ser
rating and the impact of uh net
neutrality and whether this is a good
thing or a bad thing and uh giving
connectivity for free to people to uh
you know some people have concerns that
this may create monopolies at the
application service so they say for
emerging markets this may be a great
thing so this is for Sharon about the
panel in general what do you think is
going to happen with zero rating or
sponsor Based Services and net
neutrality right well first let me tell
you what has happened um which is that
uh so in the US uh net neutrality order
they did not uh say Z so first of all
let me make sure everyone knows what
zero rating is sorry zero rating is the
idea that you can get uh you don't get
charged for the bits for certain
applications um on your data plan so if
you have a a mobile broadband plan and
it has you know some data limitation you
know two gigabytes a gigabites a month
gigabytes a month for example uh but
you're using Facebook uh you know the
Facebook bits don't count against those
two gigabits gigabytes sorry um that
would be an example of zero ating I the
reason I I'm not trying to pick on
Facebook it's just that they've been one
of the most active proponents of this
idea in emerging markets in particular
and as I'm sorry I didn't know your name
um okay as he mentioned um there's pros
and cons right the pro is uh you know
for people in Emerging Markets with very
little uh ability to pay for services
they get some data services right they
get an experience of data services that
they wouldn't have otherwise uh on the
other hand if there's a home if there is
or would have been a homegrown Facebook
they won't ever see it because it will
never come to pass because the users
would have to pay to access the
Homegrown Facebook and they you know the
existing incumbent social network will
will be the one that they know of um
that's one critique another one is you
know it's like Facebook trying to
redefine what the internet is and we've
seen all of those uh debates happen uh
in very interesting ways over the past
few months um I'll go back to my
original Point what did the FCC did not
say zero rating is good or bad they
didn't say it was not okay either they
didn't also say it was okay they said um
they said uh we're not saying no but
we're going to keep watching what you're
doing industry and if you do things that
are too outrageous we'll stop you okay
uh Europe similarly did not Outlaw zero
rating but there seems to be it's a so I
should say that the European uh text I
actually first received it this morning
just came out so uh this is based on
very quick reads of you know myself and
other lawyers some of whom are in the
room some are not but uh
I'm actually not a lawyer sorry some of
the lawyers within Microsoft who have
looked at this and uh you know one uh
interpretation of what they have done is
that uh some countries in Europe the
Netherlands for example have said zero
rating is not okay uh so sorry Norway um
so uh if they uh have said zero rating
is not okay can they still say that if
the EU passes a unified set of
regulations that everybody is supposed
to follow and so that's also an open
question of will it still be not okay in
places that have said it's not okay okay
so like Chile the Norway have said it's
not okay uh so there's an open question
India was a really interesting
experience in the past I forget exactly
when it was a few months back uh I think
in April or May of this year um where uh
Indie the Indian Telecom regulator put
out a consultation asking a bunch of
questions that were mostly about whether
over-the-top Services meaning things
like Skype as opposed to traditional
voice whether over-the-top Services
should be regulated that was essentially
the gist of their questioning and it
triggered a huge uh outcry uh about
against zero rating interestingly uh and
um you know in some ways you would think
that'd be the last place that you'd have
a backlash on zero rating but it was
actually the first place where it really
blew up in in a market where there are
many people who are unserved so it's
gone both ways it has this exactly the
pros and cons you talked about thank you
Sharon uh do you have a follow-up
question Pablo or is that good um more
questions from the
audience so I'm curious about um so we
we you know we've talked about um um
crowd sourcing and uh point-to-point
architectures as ways to address some of
the challenges you know and sorry I
apologize I'm not a not really an expert
in this domain so apologize my question
is worded poorly um and and it seems
like small cells Pico cells right we're
talking about having access points
placed very close together and so I'm
curious from a technical perspective are
there um are there advantages to
crowdsourcing this and say you know
placing access points for this type of
network um in end users homes and you
know just attaching it to their their
home network connection you know maybe
for low latency and and from a policy
perspect so if technically that's a good
thing then from a policy perspective how
do we get there uh so you're can I
that's yeah so you're talking about
placing a bay station potentially inside
the user's uh home yeah inside user's
home or even like you know encouraging
users to place an antenna facing
outwards to serve the street or whatever
and then they get maybe you know a
kickback on their sure internet service
so they that actually is already done
except for the kickback part so there's
a you can get a device called a fto cell
right now and in fact there's a and so a
fto cell you will install in a home or
private re residence but it'll run on
the operator's spectrum and you can
connect there and then what's called an
Open Access model if you if somebody
sees the signal outside the uh um
outside under the street they can they
can connect uh and that's Obviously good
for the operator because they're
leveraging the your back hul which is a
major part of the cost which is what I
was saying and they're in fact actually
more fto cells today than there are base
stations so they're actually wide fairly
widely uh deployed that being said
nobody they don't give you a kickback
most of the operators maybe they uh you
know potentially they should and
definitely I think when you're looking
at some of these Technologies like
millimeter wave where the indoor
coverage becomes a real problem because
you can't these Technologies can get
outside but you getting inside will be
impossible it really does having a third
party leveraging third party back haul
and a third party ownership of that
access point becomes much more relevant
and I think you're going to see that
business model become more widely
used what you're describing is happening
today except that it's not in the
millimeter waves it's in Wi-Fi um that
is exactly what Wi-Fi first CA ca's
version of Wi-Fi first in the US and
there's a company in Europe called f
that's doing the same thing phone uh so
the way the cable one in the US Works um
so Comcast for example is doing this
they give you a home router uh they've
been going around the country upgrading
those home routers so it's got two ssids
right one of them is your personal one
and the other one is the one for the
street um and it's leveraging the back
hall that you're paying for now as long
as uh you know as long as a you trust
that they did the security right so that
isn't letting people into your network
at home and B they don't charge you with
a data cap so that you know when your
neighbor when the guy drives down your
street and uses your Wi-Fi it's
affecting your bill people are like oh
this is great right and so that's
actually how they're doing the Wii first
which is essentially what you're talking
about it's a crowdsourced uh solution so
I guess my follow-up question is is from
a technical perspective do we see um
home internet connections progressing to
a point where they can supply the ne
Neary back hall bandwidth to you know to
service these you know the kind of
bandwidth that's necessary to have an
right now at least on average the home
back hall capacity is much larger than
on the average capacity even if
everybody opened up their back home back
hul to it uh to the no they might not
want to do that but the average capacity
would be relatively small um on
comparison so there is enough there's
actually much more back Back hul
available which is unused in some sense
and that is a good op you know uh
opportunistically to use that back haul
as a potential way to get around the
back hall problem which is a big cost
Factor but but it doesn't solve the
problem in non-residential areas right
so like of course the parts of New York
City he was showing they might be a mix
but depends if you're in a downtown area
where there's or you know you're on a
road with a big rush hour traffic and
you're trying to get more capacity into
that area yeah it's not going to help on
a highway or something in a suburb where
there's no residence to hand over to
yeah but in those areas you can actually
use MIM wave as a back hall
communicating between base stations just
using highs speeded millimeter
wave on the idea of back call I have a
followup question are the operators
incentivized to instead go for
millimeter wave instead of laying new
fiber between base stations as they go
for new deployments of Base
stations can maybe okay so if you look
right now there's a mix I think uh there
a Lucent study it said about maybe I
think about 7% of Base stations right
already have millimeter wave access
point I'm not sure if it's so much The
Operators have a number of factors um
one thing is whether they have the
availability of the fiber so in the
United States for example AT&T and
Verizon actually own fiber in certain
markets and then they would use that and
then in other areas like Korea um fiber
is very cheap and then they would go for
that but in cases where the back hul
where they have to lease that fiber that
can actually become extremely expensive
and that if you look at the operating
expenses for uh op cells it's almost
back all sometimes like 30 50% of the
Opex and in that case then the
millimeter wave would make sense so I
think it's um there are incentives that
would U Already push them in certain
scarios it depends on the availability
of the
fiber okay thank you s any other
comments so just a a fact I think Google
has set up some certain tests where they
trying to use millimet wave to connect
to in residential home so that you know
set up the the back ho so it's starting
to
happening I think we have a question
right there right uh this question for
the street professors um when you're
doing your uh minim wave
research what do you desire the industry
to participate I mean can how can
industry help or what you hope the
industry can do that will make uh your
research uh more um better or more
productive aside from giving us money we
giving you a money
no I think now is basically um providing
suitable platforms because a lot of time
for Academia to develop these platform
which we're trying to do now is they
take time they take money we have to
apply for a very large NSF Grant in
order to supply that we did that
um but I I think that providing us the
the right platform a powerful
reconfigure platform for example Sora
and that will definitely speed up the
process I think now it's very difficult
to developing or testing or verifying
our our protocols because we just don't
have suitable hardware and a lot of
Industry they just don't want to give it
to us because they are startups and
they're just you know they're using this
to um to to get their own market share
so it's very difficult for us to ask
some to for those platform but if
Microsoft can support these that would
be
awesome same answer as header actually I
also know there are lot of 60 Hardware
platform for example from one from
qualcom U they have the capability for
example operating on the 60 band and
running e to do ad protocol but they are
just opening up it as completely a black
box we can get nothing useful out of it
if we can get a little bit of
information like even receive the signal
strings that will actually speed up a
lot of research right now we don't have
them yet yeah I completely agree in
addition um to the need for a platform
the other thing as I'm hoping maybe a
company like Microsoft could do is for
people at least at my layer more in the
F and Mac may try to understand work
with them to understand how the network
and applications would um
work and because and also from other
industrial Partners if you're like AT&T
which would know the actual realistic
economics of networking I think that
what that to least to me is a bit of a
mystery and that's where I think we
could get a lot of collaboration at
least particularly in this
room I have another questions for the
street professors um so all of you
choose to do uh to pick on walk uh minim
wave as the are to work on but the title
of this section is 5G can you comment
about other 5G Technologies uh like what
I heard about like massive myo
Distributing myo densification or even
codification um I agree that we did not
uh get all speakers and all those
Technologies but I I I think uh we have
Paul here who's uh talking to all the 5G
folks so I'm going to defer the question
to Paul as to like where are those
technology St
let's see in the last panel session I
said something about organized chaos um
and I guess I I mean I don't really know
how to answer the question I think it's
it's it's the right question the
question I was going to ask the panel
actually was in all this chaos of
multiple Technologies what needs to
happen for them to get rationalized into
something that can be General an actual
benefit to the business ecosystem and to
the sort of global connectivity
ecosystem and get out of the mode of
sort of research projects I can't answer
the all Technologies question uh at this
point myself
so so my partial answer is I think
important thing is as we add more
technology more radio technology on top
of each other they all going to
integrate into smart hul how they
actually interact with each other what
time what do you use do you use them
simultaneously do you use it
alternatively I think that's a good
question to us even for 60 GHz or
millimeter wave it will actually provide
you capacity but it won't provide you
continuous connectivity there will be
time that you are just in a very awkward
location that there's no flexion will
reach you you're blocking all the waves
in that way you fall back to LTE or fall
back to Wi-Fi and you can also leverage
LTE to do coordination for you in the
sense so how do these technology
interact with each other I think that's
another interesting question among that
for 5G or 7 8
n u thank you heather I I I think a big
comment that I have on 5G is that all
the technologies that you are
considering at this point U the economic
benefits have not been clearly marked
out so I think those will decide which
Technologies sort of end up taking off
so they're still in Prototype mode and
and debate mode for from my
understanding is that correct
Sharon
um I I think that the
um you know it's very interesting what
drives a cellular operator to deploy a
new generation of Technology at all why
would they do it at all um you know
because it's just more more expense for
them it's big investment and you know
are they going to get more Revenue right
so you know one Theory so for example if
you go back to 4G why did Verizon come
out in the US way ahead in 4G you know
what made them come out you know let's
do LTE let's really drive it let's
advertise it let's Market it uh you know
one theory is that AT&T had an exclusive
on the iPhone and they were killing
Verizon and that's what drove at Verizon
to say let me differentiate my network
and have something that I can market and
brand and you know it'll be the fast
Network and they'll have the nice phone
and I'll have the fast Network um so
that's why I came back to the sort of
competition policy issue the economics
are hugely important I I you know I
admire what you're doing with 60
gigahertz because I completely agree
with you that if you don't have to pay
for the Spectrum you know it costs a lot
less uh so you know and it also opens up
other models of how uh you know
non-traditional players can enter the
space uh but um you know is there a
desire to do it I mean in the past
what's usually happened is that uh you
know each generation there was some big
technological Advance you know went from
analog to digital and then we went from
digital to internet basically uh right
from from circuit to packet if you will
um so this time around I think it's a
little less clear because we already
went to packet and once we're at packet
then it becomes better faster cheaper
just like wired networks right I've got
I can do the internet now the question
is you know can I do it faster you know
is there first of all what's the
trajectory of actual demand for that you
know we we but it's always gone like
this but that doesn't necessarily mean
it always will most likely yes but you
know we don't know uh and the second is
I if if people do want better faster
cheaper how do how do I as an operator
distinguish myself so that I can make
more money and what I see happening is
the conversation is I want to be the
service provider because that's where
I'm going to make more money I don't
make money by selling bits you know and
I think one of two things will happen
either some operator out there who will
likely be one of those little disruptive
ones if they don't get merged out of
existence some operator out there will
say actually I can make money by being
really good and fast and cheap and I
have a really dumb pipe but it's really
cheap and people will buy it and they
will like it and they will come to me
and I will make money and the Other
Extreme is uh actually I make money
because I have some unique service that
people have to come to my network to get
right and um and to do that I have a
very tightly Integrated Network where I
have you know all all of the services
are in my network close to my user with
low latency and I can do all sorts of
things that other people can't do you
hear a lot of that discussion in 5G
that's that's sort of but but it's I
think Su and I were talking about at
lunch you know it's not super clear
exactly what those apps would be that
would fall into that profile but uh you
know they could exist
so want to take Omar's question and then
we can come back to no go ahead
um I was going to comment on on a
different topic than millimeter wave
although I'm I'm very close to this area
I love it and I think um Spectrum
offload in any parts of the spectrum is
going to really Drive um utilization of
of 60 gahz the one that I have that
basically uh kept me up uh all night and
and sometimes is how do you optimize
radio resources for over the top I had a
reason why I was looking looking at that
problem and I went and approach some
operators and infrastructure vendors
anywhere from
Vodafone uh to Samsung and Ericson so on
so and they all kind of like it's like a
deer with a headlight shine in their in
their face and the reason was why I was
looking at it because I you know I work
for Skype and Skype and Skype for
business is over the toop
application it's very demanding on the
radio resources for the cellular network
and it's interesting and the comment
that is related to 5G in general that
all of the ones I asked independently
said oh this is a topic for 5G so this
is a comment it's not really a question
if you have a comment on this I would
really like to understand your views on
that um maybe I'm going to if I can
answer back or put the question back to
you because even within the 4G they made
a lot of uh infrastruct changes in the
evolved packet core as you might know at
the Gateway you can offer theoretically
the operator can provide quality of
service you can open a bearer with a
specific quality of service and then in
principle the operator could provide
open that up and say okay to Skype if
you want you you can go along this uh
path and then you know we'll change the
scheduling decisions of course they'
probably have to reimburse Skype would
have to pay for that or something and
maybe gets into Network neutrality but
generally those there's a huge
infrastructure in that but it's never
used and everything is just going over
best effort so I just kind of comment on
that you're right there is a huge
infrastructure out there that relies
quite a bit on De packet inspection and
what happens every time we have an
upgrade a software upgrade it breaks the
DPI so that's one of the reasons why
it's not fully used to give you an
example going from link 2013 to Sky for
business which is our new product what
all Wi-Fi wireless controllers that are
using deep packet in inspection Cisco
Aruba miru
they all broke so you know and you can
imagine what the escalations were like
but in any any point my point is uh
actually operators fully recognize this
and we are I'm in deep discussions with
these operators to how do we do this
without violating net neutrality good
luck with that right Sharon I mean it's
like but but I I think if if there are
thoughts that come to mind I definitely
would like to
engage what was your last if there are
thoughts that come to mind on how you
optimize the radio
resources for like overthe toop
applications I feel like it's not it's
less a technical question because we
understand at least in Academia maybe
too much on quality of service and the
even the network standards have already
put in a lot of standard support for
that and it seems like most of it is a
business and maybe I'm wrong that that
that is a business issue of getting a
you know getting an arrangement with a
particular service Prov content provider
to actually utilize the mechanisms to
you know Target that maybe I don't I
don't see a I don't see a technical
barrier to you know providing pref
preferential service because you know we
know about scheduling policies we know
about how to Mark those and the whole
network infrastructure so just quick 10
seconds and I will stop here because I
I'm sorry I've taken a lot of that time
at and this is take Skype for example or
or Whatsapp or what have you you have
viip you have some of them have uh video
so on so forth it's not a matter of
knowing it's Skype by doing some deep
pack and inspection and prioritizing
that you have to know the modality and
these modalities like VoIP has different
performance and you need different power
control and you need different
prioritization than video than uh app
sharing than content sharing this is
what actually we were looking for it's a
bit more specific I suppose but I I I
also see your point that there's a lot
of
literature out there that one has to
look at thanks I I I think what he's
talking about are these are UCI codes
qci codes or there there's a name for
the codes but oh yeah Q yeah qci qci and
LTE that uh that um uh in other words
that to your point about the modalities
arm you know we the phone would tell the
network here's what I'm doing and this
is the kind of performance that I need
and there is nothing in net neutrality
that prevents that what does prevent and
in fact there's nothing in net
neutrality that says that an ISP can't
manage their Network and decide to make
vo packets go ahead of video packets if
they want to what it does say is they
can't require payment for it and I think
that's where that's the challenge is I
think what what suip is saying is the
challenge is the business model not the
technology the technology exists in
order for the Ott to tell the network
this is what I need that challenge but
but you're not
agreeing
no
uh yeah let's take this question offline
at this point but uh let's thank our
speakers for their talks and questions
thank you so
much and they'll be available offline if
you have more questions thanks again
thank you